bei geimpften ist es so dass man oft
schon symptome hat bevor man überhaupt
ansteckend ist war die impfung führt
dazu dass sozusagen der körper sehr
schnell reagiert noch wenig viruslast
und dann erst kommen die wehren und
anstatt die viruslast wir sehen uns auch
einer der gründe weshalb quasi die wir
die impfungen die panne begrenzen weil
sehr häufig sind die leute schon mit
symptomen unterwegs und bleiben dann
auch zu hause noch bevor sie wirklich
ansteckend sind weil bei demjenigen der
geimpft ist die symptome oft beginnen
bevor die viruslast sehr hoch ist
da kommen sie auf temperatur habe ich
mir sagen na ja
es ist nur halt computer sind also woher
weiß er dass er fast bezieht er sich und
es ist ein schönes beispiel dass wir von
anfang an der krise ich sag das jetzt
mal klar deutlicher schritte von
dilettanten blendern und scharlatanen
informiert werden ja es geht es treten
leute medial auf dominieren die meinung
dominieren die politischen
entscheidungen die völlig fakten frei
völlig frei von qualifikationen da ihre
empfehlungen geben wenn verlauten ich
meine damit zum beispiel in lauterbach
ich meine zum beispiel auch herr
montgomery oder herrhausen ja ich habe
bin vernetzt mit den champions leagues
experten zu diesen themen ja weil ich
wissenschaftlichen symposium
veranstaltet haben habe ich ein
wahnsinnig gutes netzwerk das sind die
führende nun erst drin das sind
ehemalige leiter von
universitätskliniken sander ist der herr
schrappe treten da ist daher anders
drehen das sind die top leute und die
kommen nicht zu wort und es ist völlig
verrückt wir leben an der wirklichkeit
vorbei und deswegen haben wir von anfang
an der korona krise nehmen wir in der
lüge über 1 das corona virus hat er das
potenzial des gibt deutsche
gesundheitswesen zu überlasten
zahlen was schätzen sie denn wie viel
war denn die belegung gewesen der
krankenkassen werde eine unterbelegung
von 16 prozent immer noch von der von
den unter belegten krankenhäusern waren
zwei prozent kuwait patienten wir wissen
dass die ort meistens falsch montiert
waren ja wo ist denn da bitteschön die
bedrohung für das gesundheitsmesse das
ist ein völliger unsinn also endlich ist
nicht dass sie zahlen
ich habe im krankenhaus gearbeitet die
pflegekräfte sind abgezogen wir haben
massiv zu kämpfen gehabt mit diesen
schwerstkranken sterben dass sie
widersprechen den zahlen des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums ist auf
homepage ist die leipziger natürlich so
jemanden sondern eine unmittelbare
persönliche erfahrung die uns jetzt zwei
jahre begleitet hat und jetzt endlich
diese situation durch die impfungen wir
haben den griff gekriegt hatte die wahl
durch die war doch richtig sind wie war
denn die belegung der charité also ich
finde im vergleich zu 18 1 sie machen
hier wieder panik und die masse die
machen
ich beziehe mich hier auf die klaren zu
einer leipzig analyse die von der
bundesregierung beauftragt worden ist
sind also diese diese berufe dieser
studie unter steht eindeutig drin wir
hatten historische unterbelegung in den
corona jahren und davon zwei prozent
cupid patienten entschuldigen andere
länder auch die pandemie bereits in
england ja ist denn da bitteschön die
überbelastung die wir nie dagewesen ja
und dann die liebe nummer zwei
der test weist keine infektion nach der
test weist nach virus trümmer ja also
jemand ohne symptome ist nicht krank ist
aber ständig in die instanzen
eingeflossen lüge nummer 23 die impfung
ist
sicher die impfung schützt schauen sie
doch mal den die zahlen an der
krankenkassen der kassenärztlichen
vereinigung wir haben dramatische
zunahme von diagnosen wir haben
dramatische zunahme von
impfnebenwirkungen das ist alles fakt
und diese impfung ist eben nicht eine
masern impfung oder eine grippeimpfung
sondern sie sagt eine bedingte zulassung
und da muss man einfach mal eine text
lesen die bedingten zulassung wie hoch
die idee der anspruch der in der im
surfer überwachung ist und uns schon
twitter und deswegen
nein
zur sache dass ich sagen kann man ja
noch
schritte was sie können was die kleinen
etwas ist das ich glaube ich als es ist
ja wirklich sie sind ja die sind ja der
patient sie sind ja derjenige der an die
das alles adressiert wird aber sie
müssen wirklich wissen es und ich muss
es nicht nachweisen dass es kausal ist
nicht ich sondern die diese jährige der
die seite die das verfrüht zulässt muss
nachweisen dass das nicht kausal ist es
ein unterschied und diese studien die
sie selber auch genannt haben werden
nicht gemacht an der charité war ein
forscher der hat versucht so eine studie
zu machen die charité hat ihn
zurückgepfiffen wir haben hier wirklich
wir lassen die leute ins offene messer
laufen und diese experten die ich als
dilettanten bezeichnung deshalb das
nenne ich auch lauterbach dazu die haben
oft knallharte interessenskonflikte ja
wenn herr montgomery zb hier ständig von
der katastrophe spricht
er ist wissenschaftlicher beirat einer
firma die mit infektion handelt genauso
wie hirschhausen lauterbach hat in
seiner karriere schon sehr viele
gefährliche medikamente gefeatured wird
dann vom markt genommen worden sind ja
sehr fragwürdig überhaupt sehr viel
sollte man fragwürdig gerberweg ins
aber wir können so nicht weitermachen
wir müssen ehrlich die top leute holen
und die top epidemiologen die top
infektiologen und die top el sol
forscher die die
politik bestimmen lassen mit dieter
hundt das sagen was jetzt auch durch
gesetzen umgesetzt wurde also herr frank
intrinsity ich muss nochmal ganz klar
sagen was sie hier verbreiten das ist
ich verstehe das gar nicht ihre
persönliche meinung ich wollte es gerade
sagen propaganda das wollte ich nicht
kann ich sagen was ist aber dass man als
lassen sie doch auch mal aus kanada
sie werden mit irgendwas verbandelt und
verbunden also ich keine ahnung also
davon weiß ich nichts und ich kenne
viele namhafte internationale
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
epidemiologen virologen infektiologen
die absolut diese haltung teilen dass
uns die impfung aus dieser krise zum
teil raus geführt hat die krise ist
nicht überwunden muss man ganz klar
sagen die maske schützt uns wenn wir das
wollen wir brauchen selbstverständlich
eigenverantwortung jeder muss auch
schauen dass er für sich und für sein
umfeld das richtige tut und ich glaube
da ist die ganze gesellschaft auf ganz
ganz stark sensibilisiert aber die daten
und fakten die ich kenne die
entsprechend nicht in keinster weise dem
was sie hier vergisst du also ich
versteh deswegen hat es sind in ihren
zahlen egal der krankenkassen sind ihnen
die über sterblichkeit egal die mit der
impfkampagne seitlich zusammen ist das
in alles egal wissen sie was ich glaube
ich glaube dass sich die
verantwortlichen für diese
personalpolitik irgendwann vor gericht
wegen fahrlässiger tötung zu
verantworten haben das wird kommen es
geht gar nicht anders weil diese opfer
die wir inzwischen schon haben ja die
die wirklichkeit die klopft nicht mehr
wirklich an die tür die dritte karte ein
und das ist absolut absolut nicht
hinnehmbar was ich ja sagen beim thema
corona werden wir nicht mehr auf einen
grünen zweig kommen aber das wollen wir
auch gar nicht streit ist er hier
erlaubt wir gehen einen ganz kurzen
unterbrechung gekommen damit zwei
spannenden ganz anderen themen zurück